بدا العدو العكسي لاعاده فتح ابواب
البرلمان التونسيه الموصده منذ ال 25 من
يوليو تموز العام الماضي عقب قرار تجميده
ثم اعلان حله نهائيا في الثلاثين من مارس
اذار العمل الجاري
1055 مرشحا سيخوضون حملتهم للانتخابات
التشريعيه المقرر لاجراءها في السابعه عشر
من ديسمبر كانون الاول ضمن ضوابط وقواعد
جديده اقررها القانون الانتخابيه الجديد
المؤرخ في الخامس عشر من سبتمبر العمل
الجاري من بين هذه الضوابط والقواعد التي
جاء بها القانون الجديد الى الغاء نظام
الاقتراع على القوائم وتعوده بالاقتراع
على الافراد كما عوض القانون طريقه
التمثيل النسبي بالاغلبيه
المطلقهم مجرد ارقام يمثلون محليات يصلى
عليهم السيف سحب الوكاله اذا لم يلتزموا
ببرنامج من الانتخابي المح الذي يتناقض
ولا يتكامل مع مشروع الحزب الوطني الكبير
كما حدد القانون ضمانه تغطيه الاعلاميه
متساويه بمعادل 3 دقائق لكل مترشح وهو
معتبره البعض شرطاجيسيا حتى انه احدث
خلافا بين هيئه الانتخابات وهيئه الاتصال
السمعي والبصري فكيف يمكن الوسائل الاعلام
السمعيه والبصريه تغطيه الحمله الانتخابيه
هو التمكين 1055 مترشحا من تغطيه اعلاميات
معدل ثلاث دقائق لكل منهم مع عباس قد
يتجاوز الخمس ساعات يوميا